do you love music of course you do you
need headphones here's how to pick the
perfect pair the most popular kind of
headphone is the over ear variety they
have large ear cups that fit around and
over your ears the pads form a seal
against your skin blocking out the noise
of the world around you while keeping
your Justin Bieber deep cuts from
leaking out trust us it's for the best
look for a pair with pads big enough to
fit all the way around your ears go
Goldilocks and find the pair that fits
you just right over ears have some key
advantages they're the most comfortable
kind of headphone and they sound really
great disadvantages well they're bulky
it's fine for the office but if you're a
commuter or you travel a lot look for a
pair that folds on ear headphones look a
lot like overhears but they're smaller
and they sit directly on your ears it's
the name because the pads are pressing
on your lobes on ears can be less comfy
than over ears especially if you wear
glasses they also don't offer as much of
isolation but they're much more compact
and travel friendly especially if they
fold up the last kind of headphones are
in ears true to their name you push them
right inside your ear canal this can
feel kind of weird if you're not used to
it and people with oddly shaped ears may
have a tough time finding a pair that
fits comfortably here's the secret you
want to make sure that the rubber tips
on the bud to make a complete seal on
the inside of your ear canal without
that seal music will be quiet and won't
have any bass if you feel like you're
not getting a good seal just gently
twist the earphone until you feel the
seal form and the music gets Richard
that supreme isolation is perfect for
airplanes busy commutes for times when
you just want to be alone with your
music
just stay alert because you really can't
hear what's happening around you